jetzt ist es endlich untersucht während
eines spektakulären außenbordeinsatz
wurde das corpus delicti also das loch
an der außenhülle der syoss ms09 näher
untersucht es geht um das loch in der
schule das im sommer zu einem
dramatischen druckabfall an bord der
internationalen raumstation iss geführt
hatte was dort gefunden wurde und warum
der weltraumeinsatz anders gelaufen ist
als geplant jetzt sind klicks um
science-fiction hier gibt's täglich
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal dann verpasst er kein video
herzlich willkommen
[Musik]
es war eine dramatische situation im
letzten august an bord der uss es wurde
ein leck in der raumstation iss
festgestellt stück für stück wurden die
shots der module geschlossen um den ort
der undichtigkeit 1 zu retten
schließlich stieß die besatzung auf ein
loch in einer angedockten sojus-kapsel
und zwar genau der mit der alexander
gerst am 6 juni zur iss gestartet war
und jetzt auch wieder zurück fliegen
wird es wurde ein produktionsfehler ein
metroid oder einriss vermutet doch ein
ehemaliger kosmonaut meldete sich zu
wort maxim surajew äußerte sie sehr
beunruhigende vermutungen dass ein
besatzungsmitglied je sabotiert haben
könnte der staatlichen
nachrichtenagentur ria nowosti sagte er
dass es nicht ausgeschlossen werden
könne dass ein besatzungsmitglied zitat
diese seltsamen nummer abgezogen hat wir
sind alle menschen und jeder könnte nach
hause wollen die nasa hatte die aufnahme
des loches damals aus dem netz genommen
wohl weil sie ziemlich erschreckend ist
wir hatten sie wieder aus dem netz
gefischt und so sah es damals aus man
sieht deutlich dass es bei der möglichen
ich sage mal tat mehrfach versucht wurde
anzusetzen der bohrer ist mehrere male
abgerutscht bevor er dann griff und das
loch bohrt die besatzung fand das loch
dann und nach absprache mit russischen
und amerikanischen fluglotsen wurde es
von innen repariert besser gesagt
gestopft der kosmonaut sergej prokofjew
benutzt dazu ein gase tuch und
epoxidharz und das mit erfolg seit der
reparatur konnte der druck aufrecht
gehalten werden jetzt wagten sich die
beiden kosmonauten oleg kononow eco und
sergej prokofjew von der russischen
raumfahrtagentur roskosmos sich nun aus
dass es zudem bereits von innen
lokalisierten loch
an der außenhülle der sojus-kapsel ms09
welche anders raesfeld module im
russischen segment der internationalen
raumstation angedockt es zitat es ist
eine herausforderung sergej und ich
nehmen sie an sagte contango vor
verlassen der ss ziel der beiden
kosmonauten war es die ursache der lex
herauszufinden und proben des nun an der
außenseite ausgetretenen epoxid haasis
zu nehmen um an das loch zu gelangen
setzte sich contango auf das ende eines
strehla kranes während sein kollege
prokofjew am anderen ende stand und ihn
lenkte schlussendlich wurde ein weiterer
ausleger aufgebaut und das alles kostete
extrem zeit- und prokofjew erreichte
ebenfalls das loch dort durchtrennten
die beiden kosmonauten mit einem messer
sowie einer langsam schwere teile der
braun goldenen isolierung schicht der
sojus kapsel und entfernten teile der
isolierung und des orbital
schutzschildes material reste flogen
davon und bildeten kleine wolken aus
trümmern
zitat das ist genau das loch nachdem wir
gesucht haben berichtet contango nachdem
sie die schichten abgezogen hatten
welche das leck verdeckten mit hilfe
einer pinzette und einem tupfer
extrahierte kononenko schließlich proben
des dunklen epoxy tages das ist genau
das harz mit dem das loch von innen
geflickt wurde
diese proben wurden sorgfältig verpackt
und sollen für eine analyse nun zur erde
zurückgebracht werden es soll untersucht
werden wie gut dass epoxy tat für solche
reparaturen wirklich geeignet ist lasst
uns nicht hetzen lasst uns schritt für
schritt vorgehen um nicht zu vermasseln
sagte der konzernlenker
während der live übertragenen mission
der außeneinsatz lief allerdings nicht
wie geplant statt sechs stunden
benötigten die kosmonauten fast 8
aufgrund der länge des außeneinsatzes
verzichteten die kosmonauten in
rücksprache mit den fluglotsen auf die
reparatur der offengelegten stelle mit
einer ersatz isolierung decke das ganze
ist jetzt also offen allerdings bedeutet
dass keine gefahr denn das original
teile an dem sie gearbeitet haben wird
bei wiedereintritt der kapsel in die
erdatmosphäre abgeworfen und beim
eintritt in die erdatmosphäre wird es
verglühen noch immer ist aber damit
nicht klar wer diesen schaden warum wowi
verursacht hat wenn es dazu mehr infos
gibt erfahrt ihr es natürlich hier also
ab
pixum und wenn ihr euch für noch mehr
science interessiert dann schaut auch
mal beim raumzeit lockt der zukunft
vorbei dafür hier klicken und da drunter
geht es weiter mit einem video direkt
von den kollegen das fermi paradoxon
erste antworten bis dann bleibt dran und
guckt das video sehr spannend